íbamos a hacer un vídeo sobre lo mal que está el Aston Villa y justo cuando nos decidimos a hacerlo
también sabemos que Monchi se va a marchar del equipo villano, así que todo en uno. ¿Qué está pasando en el Aston Villa?
El Aston Villa amigos que está en un momento muy difícil, en un momento complicado porque ahora mismo
cuando grabamos este vídeo es decimo octavo y lleva tres puntos.
Yo iba a hacer Nacho y un vídeo sobre las canteras de los equipos de la Premier League, luego iba a hacer un equipo
analizando sólo deportivamente al Villa, y al final he tenido que hacer un vídeo analizando todo lo que está pasando
ahora mismo en Birmingham. Como dijiste tú hace unas semanas, es una frase que me voy a quedar, ojalá dedicarme al periodismo
del cine, periodismo de peliculitas, vas a la Premier, ves una peli y te es muy buena, 7 de 10, te vas a tu casa,
no pasa nada, es que se ha acogido porque es Alejandro G. Calvo, él va a ver sus pelis, dice si le ha molao y todo el mundo
le quiere, no cae mal a nadie creo. Y no pasan cosas de que el director deportivo de la legopelícula no se va
y llega el director deportivo de Avatar, esas cosas no suceden. Yo estoy con un guión sobre equipos que han desaparecido
y a mi se desapareció. No, dijo este paso que va a desaparecer en las zumbilas porque madre mía como está la cosa
ya os estaba diciendo que van de cimo octavos en esta temporada de la Premier League que llevan sólo 3 puntos
aún no han ganado ni un solo partido de liga y sólo han marcado un gol, hace un año eran terceros con 12 puntos
y 4 victorias, ahí tenéis la comparación entre las dos temporadas, pues fíjate yo creo que una IMEI te cambiaría
y a cambio está como estaba. Pues sí, y tú dirás, el Ville ha tenido el calendario más difícil de toda la Premier League
se han enfrentado a todo el Big Six, se han enfrentado los Lover Trotters, no se han enfrentado a ningún Big Six
han jugado contra el Newcastle que además es un Newcastle sin Woltemar de Ixinvisa, han perdido dos veces contra el Bramford
tanto en Copa de la Liga en los penantis como luego en Liga, empataron contra el Everton, empataron contra Sanderlán con 10
y además también recibieron una goleada del Cristal Palace. Habiendo presentado...
Y todo esto insisto con la noticia de que se va a Monchi de su puesto, de su puesto, eso sí, luego os lo explicaremos
pero también por daros un poco ese titular que ahora hablaremos de eso en este vídeo, pero antes, ¿qué le pasa al Ville?
Con todo esto vamos a intentar desengranar qué le está pasando al Ville a nivel deportivo y luego qué está pasando en los despachos del equipo villano
Lo primero es que es un equipo evidentemente sin gol, han tardado cinco partidos en marcar un gol en la Premier League
de hecho, tras la cuarta jornada eran el único equipo de las siete primeras divisiones inglesas que todavía no había marcado en Liga
es la primera vez en la historia del club que se queda sin marcar en las primeras cuatro jornadas de Liga
no de Premier League, no de primera división, no, en general nunca habían tardado más de cuatro jornadas en marcar en una Liga
El primer gol del equipo de Unai Emery lo marcó Matías, desde aquí parece un golazo espectacular, pero es una cantada de Roofs
el portero de Sunderland bastante grande y lo metió tras 427 minutos de competición
tan solo dos equipos en la historia de la Premier League han tardado más en marcar
el Newcastle de la temporada 05-06 que tardó 438 minutos y el Crystal Palace de la temporada 17-18 que estuvo siete partidos sin marcar
641 minutos
Ahí está!
Idolo!
Como que no? Ah no, no está aquí?
No está aquí, ¿dónde estás Frank?
Sí, míalo, míalo, ahí está
Un momento
Mira Frank, ahí está
Esto una vez tuvo pegamento
Suscribite, suscribite
Bueno, que solo han tenido un peor arranque goleador una vez en Newcastle y una vez en el Crystal Palace
Bueno, si queréis algún dato más son el equipo número 12 en disparos tan solo están a seis tiros del sexto
así que alguno podría pensar en este caso que es un tema de puntería
pero es de creación de juego porque en el Aston Villa tenemos al equipo con menos goles esperados de toda la liga
tan solo 3,7 goles esperados generados, es decir 0,74 por partido
Os lo traduzco, según la estadística avanzada han generado por calidad de sus ocasiones menos de 4 goles
según lo lógico que dice la estadística avanzada que serían los goles que han debido marcar
por tanto, por partido lo lógico es que ni siquiera marquen un gol
Es increíble, o sea que normalmente cuando vemos estas cosas es que los equipos están fallando ocasiones clarísimas
que van a terminar metiendo, pero no es el caso
el mejor ejemplo se ve con Ollie Watkins el futbolista
la gran estrella de la Aston Villa que ha llegado a los 15 goles en las últimas tres Premier League
y todavía no ha visto puerta
solo ha tirado 8 veces en 5 partidos y ha generado 1,1 expected goals
siendo el tercero con más diferencia entre sus goals y expected goals por detrás de Dani Wohlbeck y Ahmad Diallo
de todas formas, según la estadística avanzada Watkins tendría que haber metido un gol
o sea no es que Watkins esté fallando ocasiones clarísimas
ni él está acertado ni le están encontrando en zonas de remate
vamos a ver el mapa de toques de Ollie Watkins según Juegyscorp
en los partidos contra el Everton y contra el Sunderland
contra el Sunderland tiene tres toques en el área y contra el Everton tiene un toque en el área
y ahí le ves súper esquinado
es muy difícil pedirle al delantero inglés que meta goles si ni siquiera le están llegando pases
para que nos entendáis está atacando hacia la izquierda el Aston Villa
y por eso veis esos toques de Ollie Watkins que está sufriendo bastante en su participación
con el Aston Villa en ataque en esta temporada
pero no es el único que ahora mismo está pasando por un valle de rendimiento
porque otra de las estrellas de este equipo Morgan Rogers también está sufriendo el bajón de todo el conjunto
lleva 0,82 disparos por partido mientras que el año pasado acabó con 1,59
lo mismo está pasando con los pases claves de Morgan Rogers que está promediendo 0,82
cuando venía de 1,47 es un jugador que yo estoy viendo ahora especialmente impreciso
y que además está sufriendo algo que veremos después
pero creo que explica también el bajón de rendimiento ofensivo y de la portación de Rogers
que tiene que ver con lo que está pasando detrás de él sin tampoco excluirlo a él de sus culpas
los otros dos titulares en el ataque están siendo Evan Gesand y Emy Buendía
que no esperábamos ver a Emy Buendía en 2025 con el Aston Villa siendo titular
pero así están siendo las cosas
el primero costó 30 millones procedente del Niza este verano y está teniendo una adaptación francamente complicada
y el segundo está rindiendo las cosas como son
pero la temporada pasada ya sabemos que acabó cedido en el Leverkusen jugando 89 minutos
en los primeros seis meses de Premier League con el Villa
así que también da la sensación sin despreciar el nivel de Buendía
que siempre hemos dicho aquí que nos ha parecido un muy buen futbolista en su etapa Premier
y está mejor que Morgan Rogers ahora mismo en estos primos partidos
pero vaya que a lo que voy es que suena más a una especie de adaptación incluso de parche
¿Qué piensas de la situación del club que es un argumento que se crea del todo una Imery?
El principal problema es la creación de juego
de aquí es donde tenemos que hablar de Yuri Tielemans
sin él no tiene nadie capaz de sacar el balón desde atrás y de luego también generar verdaderas ventajas
entre tres cuartos de campo
el último partido se lo perdió por lesión
parece que ya va a poder volver este fin de semana
pero Nacho recordarás que los dos primeros los jugó de media punta
jugó una posición en la que no nos gusta tanto con Onana y Camará por detrás
y ahí había un gran problema en la salida de balón de las Tombilla
de hecho sólo ha disputado 90 minutos contra el Pallas y 45 minutos contra el Everton en su posición
aunque ya hemos solo cinco partidos
es que verdaderamente Tielemans no está jugando por lesión
o por elección de una Imery porque no tiene otros jugadores en la posición en la que más destaca
y Nacho yo aquí veo tres principales problemas cuando no está Tielemans en el campo
o no está Tielemans en el centro del campo
lo primero los problemas que tiene el Villa en salida de balón
he puesto la primera imagen que esto es de una captura del partido contra el Sunderland
el que veis ahí en el área para sacar el balón es John McGinn
un futbolista que a mi me encanta pero que donde más destaca es en tres cuartos de campo
y en la gran llegada que tiene como interior diestro
pero ya le vimos a...
Zurdo, Zurdo
por la derecha
por la derecha pero siendo el Zurdo
ya le vimos en esas posiciones con Steven Gerrard en aquel Villa
y no es la posición perfecta para el futbolista escocés
luego también hay dos, tres, cuatro imágenes que voy a poner ahora
y creo que ejemplifican muy bien cuál está siendo el problema del Aston Villa
la primera es la matriz de pases del Aston Villa contra el Sunderland
que nos da OptaAnalyst
aquí lo que ves es un auténtico drama
porque las líneas entre los jugadores significan...
Esas calcitas, eh, que es justo
Bien, ahí las calcitas que apostó Jesús
las líneas significan pases que dan de un jugador a otro
Cuanta más gorda sea la línea significa que más pases hay
por ejemplo hay más pases de Konza, amáticas, que del Divu, amáticas
¿Cuál es el problema?
Que Hollywood Kings solo está conectado y por una finísima línea con Taron Minks
ni Morgan Rogers, ni McGinn, ni Kamara, ni Gesang, ni Digne, ni Emi Buendía
consiguieron conectar con Hollywood Kings contra Sunderland en un partido
que durante 60 minutos el Aston Villa jugó contra 10
Para mí en esa matriz de pases también lo que se ve es uno de los problemas que te decía antes
A la hora de activar a Morgan Rogers no solo la cantidad de pases sino la calidad de los mismos
Ya sabéis que a mí John McGinn me encanta
pero Morgan Rogers es un jugador que necesita por detrás a Yuri Tillemans
Kamara me parece que es un jugador con suficiente nivel para acompañar a Tillemans
y ser al mismo tiempo también un jugador que asuma labores de director de juego
Pero cuando veo que en la matriz de pases la línea más gruesa es la que que de Morgan Rogers
es la que lo une con John McGinn
veo que Rogers no va a recibir siempre en las mejores posiciones
ni en las mejores condiciones balones que de verdad si le puede dar Yuri Tillemans para este equipo
y es ahí donde Rogers me gusta
porque Rogers no me parece un jugador especialmente fino con el balón
ya lo he comentado más de una vez
Rogers es una máquina a la hora de correr hacia adelante con el balón
conducir, es muy difícil tirarlo al suelo
es muy difícil ganarle duelos
pero en un equipo que lo proyecte hacia adelante
y haga que el equipo acompañe a Morgan Rogers en esas conducciones
no es un jugador que ahora mismo esté explotado entre otras cosas
porque estoy viendo poco a Yuri Tillemans
sea por lesión, sea por su posición
en esa base de la jugada
Y aunque a Morgan Rogers ahí me encanta
tampoco creo que sea el jugador para filtrar pases en tres cuartos de campo
es capaz de hacerlo
pero cuando el Villa está plantado ya en campo rival
El que verdaderamente es capaz de filtrar pases
es de nuevo Yuri Tillemans
Voy aquí a poner tres gráficos seguidos
que están sacados, si no me equivoco, estos de OptaAnalyst también
en el que vais a ver los pases acertados y fallados de Gastón Villa
contra Sunderland
Aquí la primera son los pases acertados
y aquí vemos el principal problema
Ataca, por cierto, el Villa hacia la izquierda
Nadie mete un balón por dentro
Ataca por la derecha y ese número 23 es un cuchillo
No deje de dar pases cortos en el área rival
Es buenísimo
Bueno, no hay pases al área
y sobre todo no hay pases en zona central
es todo a las bandas
Vamos ahora a ver los pases fallados
Aquí ya vemos que se intentaron verdaderamente pases por el centro
pero no salieron ninguno
y luego si veis la matriz de pases general
pues veis que todos los pases que se intentaron meter
entre líneas por dentro en el área
fueron pases fallados
Tillemans es tan importante en el Villa
como para que el Villa no esté ganando ningún partido sin él
Hombre, no exageraría
Creo que con Tillemans también ha habido partidos
que igual este Villa, como no está bien Morgan Royes
como no está bien Watkins
como Dibu empezó de suplente
pues tampoco hubiera ganado
pero es evidente que por ejemplo el día de Sunderland
con el Belga en el campo
el partido hubiera sido muy diferente
Sólo los tres recién ascendidos y el Brenford
llevan menos pases claves que el Villa
está teniendo un problema de creatividad y visión de juego
el equipo Unai Emery a estas alturas de temporada
a pesar de que son el cuarto equipo con más pases en el último tercio
que esto es un grave problema a solventar
por el entrenador español
tras el último partido
Emery reconoció estar enfadado
no tanto por los resultados sino por el juego
y acusó a su equipo de ser vago
a la hora de ir a los duelos
Lazy fue la palabra que usó
y eso también creo que es un bajo en respecto al año pasado
porque tiene más que ver
no solo tiene que ver con los juegos
sino también con el ambiente que ahora mismo reina
en el equipo de la UEFA
y también con el ambiente que ahora mismo reina
en el asombi la de cierto pesimismo
por donde han estado y donde se están viendo ahora
y hacia donde se dirigen
que esto también es peligroso
no solo que está en un momento pesimista el equipo
sino que de cara al futuro hay que convencer a los jugadores
de que las cosas van a ir a mejor
y no hay muchas pruebas de ello
hemos hablado del ataque, hemos hablado del centro del campo
pero también tenemos que hablar de la debilidad defensiva
de las zombilas, esto va mucho más allá de que simplemente
tu mejor jugador
Yuri Telemans al menos en esa capacidad creativa
no esté en su posición o no esté disponible
y es que en cuanto a la defensa
es verdad que solo han encajado 5 goles
eso se lo concedo, el sexto que menos de toda la Premier League
pero son el segundo equipo
con más goles esperados en contra
con 8,3
un dato solo empiezoado
por el Burnley
es decir, la calidad de las ocasiones que les han generado
solo se supera por los clarets
de aquí vamos a ir a ver
imágenes de partido, ojalá poder poner
los vídeos y ilustrarlo de una mejor manera
pero tenemos que tirar con las capturas
y voy a ir jugador por jugador viendo
que verdaderamente el Villa también está dejando puntos
por errores puntuales de sus defensas
para mi en el lateral derecho Matica
sigue siendo un problema, ya lo era el año pasado
ha pasado un año más, las expectativas del Villa
y el nivel general de la plantilla de las zombilas
es superior al que tiene el lateral derecho polaco
y está sufriendo en casi todos los partidos que ha jugado
por ejemplo, contra el Sanderland
vamos a ver la imagen, pierde la marca
en el gol de Isidor
ahí ya veis en el círculo rojo que Isidor
ya está yendo al desmarque del gol del pase
de Grindsaca
y Maticas que era el defensor
no llega, también aquí puede ser un fallo de
Tyrone Minx que está tirando la línea del fuera de juego
más o menos en Cuenca
luego contra el Everton, no he cogido captura
porque en general es que Grillis le volvió loco
podría poner una foto de Jack Grillis
y de Maticas, pero en general
el futbolista inglés se sintió muy cómodo
atacando al lateral del Villa
y de nuevo contra el Crystal Palace
él es el culpable de que en el primer
nivel del Crystal Palace que llega
de penalti, cometido hacia Camada
él es el que pierde otra vez la marca
es una jugada muy buena el Crystal Palace
en el que Mateta le mete un pase a Camada
pero Maticas vuelve a perder la marca
tú me irás, bueno
el nivel defensivo de Maticas nunca ha sido muy bueno
el problema es que
la pareja central y especialmente Consas
sí que estaban en un gran nivel en las temporadas anteriores
y este año vuelve a anotar a Consa
un tanto fallón, recuerdo por ejemplo
un fallo suyo en el gol del Marqueji contra el Crystal Palace
que ya era el 0-2
y la pareja Pau Torres y Tyrone Minks
cuando han tenido que jugar los dos juntos
especialmente contra el Brentford
tiene una piscina bastante grande
aquí vais a ver la primera captura
como aquí están Igor Thiago y Dango Watara
emparejados 1-1
con Pau Torres y contra Tyrone Minks
y en la siguiente jugada nadie sabe muy bien por qué
Igor Thiago ya consiguió peinar el balón
Dango Watara ya está dispuesto a correr
el balón al espacio
pero es que aún así esta imagen no te imaginas
que acaba en gol
claro, claro, bien, te pido
porque Watara les gana la...fíjate donde están
Minks, Torres e incluso Maticas
es muy difícil pensar que esto va a acabar en gol
ponlo la primera imagen otra vez Jesús
aquí lo tienes, pum, están bien
se supone que están marcando hombre a hombre
y en la siguiente te has comido
la peinada de Igor Thiago y estás dispuesto
para comerte esa carrera de Dango Watara
en fin, ya veis que
es un problema ahora mismo el que está atravesando
a todos los niveles el
año pasado fueron los undécimos
con menos goles en contra esperados y este año
están en la posición
décimo novena en esa clasificación
así que como ya os decíamos solo hay un equipo peor
en cuanto a la calidad de las ocasiones que
le están generando, todo viene además de un
verano complicado y ahora es cuando entramos
en los despachos
porque ya os dijo hace poco
que las reglas del fair play
financiero habían matado a las tombilas
uso literalmente ese
ese verbo, tenéis un vídeo
explicando la situación de las tombilas
respecto al fair play financiero
pues lo dejamos por aquí arriba
como siempre, vídeo top
vamos a seguir recomendándolo porque es un vídeo top
y es un verano en el que solo han llegado
Gesand, Lindelof, Sancho,
Elliot y Marco Bisott
pero se han ido Jacob Ramsey,
Leon Bailey, Marcus Rashford y Marco
Asensio respecto al equipo de terminada
temporada pasada ya sabéis que Rashford y Asensio
no eran propiedad como tal de las
tombila, en el caso de Harvey Elliot
pero han jugado 53 minutos por ahora
y Sancho 9 en esta
Premier League, es cierto que con ellos
esperamos que haya una mejora en
los villanos, pero ahora mismo
el análisis no puede ser mucho más
optimista. Pues no, y vamos a explicar
que ha sucedido en estas últimas
horas, porque el lunes por la noche
saltó la noticia de que Monchi, el apodado
Leon San Fernando, iba a dejar
de ser director de las tombilas, según
Jacob Tanswell de The Athletic
es una mezcla entre una reacción
a un verano decepcionante como hemos comentado
y que en parte Monchi también quiere
volver a España por razones personales
según Matlow, y esto me aprecio
muy interesante, porque Matlow tiene mucha
información de los equipos de Londres, pero el es
del Villa, entonces entiendo que también
por un tema personal él le gusta informarse
del equipo villano, Matlow
dice que el Villa sentía que necesitaba un
golpe fresco, un cambio y que lo
que normalmente en un equipo sería
echar al entrenador en el Aston Villa no puede
suceder porque una G-Merry es
intocable, además John Percy también
del Telegram dice que Emery no piensa una
salida por la dios de Monchi, que eso es lo primero
que hay que aclarar Nacho, que
se vaya Monchi no significa que el proyecto
una G-Merry en Birmingham haya acabado
ni mucho menos. Durante el verano
Monchi ha estado mucho tiempo en el club
de su infancia, el San Fernando
club de, club deportivo, entiendo,
C.B., que no es Contragrafo
Detectado, que terminó
desapareciendo, ha desaparecido este
verano, mismamente, bueno, y
ha acabado fundando el San Fernando
1940, dice Diasletic
que su ausencia ha sorprendido
por los cercanos que eran tanto el
como Damian Videgaen, que ya sabéis que es el
director de fútbol del Aston Villa
se espera eso sí y por eso hacia la
aclaración al inicio del vídeo, que
Monchi siga siendo un asesor
dentro del grupo que tiene la propiedad
del Aston Villa, B Sports, mientras
reestructuran todo ese apartamento
de dirección de fútbol, por lo que la relación
entendemos que no ha terminado tan mal
como para una salida brusca.
Sí, se está criticando ahora bastante la
etapa de Monchi en el Aston Villa y también parece
un tema importante a tratar, ¿qué tal
le ha ido a Monchi en el equipo de Birmingham?
Se está poniendo mucho el ejemplo, como ahí
se ve en la siguiente foto, de que
en el último partido de Aston Villa contra Sunderland,
de los once titulares, sólo dos han
sido fichados en la etapa de Unai Emery,
Evan Gheesan y Morgan Royas.
A mí me parece también un poco
tramposo, porque normalmente estaría
Juriciel Demas también como titular, que
es otro que ha traído Monchi, Pau Torres
también ha jugado muchísimos minutos como titular,
otro que ha traído el director deportivo
español e incluso Javier Helio, te esperamos
que juegue muchísimo, así que creo que es coger
un once que es justo
el último y hacer que sea representativo
cuando realmente no creo que sea representativo.
Esos once que jugaron el otro día
de lo que va a jugar la estuartemporada
con el Villa. Además, hay un dato que me parece
muy interesante y es que desde que llegó Monchi
a Birmingham desde verano de 2023,
que coincide también con la primera
temporada completa de Unai Emery,
el Aston Villa tenía un gasto neto de 10 millones,
el equipo que menos de toda la Premier League,
solo por detrás de los Wolves,
quitando equipos como el Leeds que no han estado todas
estas temporadas en la Premier League.
En las tres temporadas previas, el Villa
gastó 140 millones, el decimotercero
que más de toda la Liga.
Si hablamos de la etapa
de Monchi en el Aston Villa, hay que hablar de una
etapa que ha estado condicionada
vamos al más no poder por el fair play
financiero y por esos salarios
tan altos que tiene Aston Villa y que no le han permitido
poder seguir fichando. Es el equipo
con menos gasto neto de toda la Premier League,
solo por detrás de los Wolves.
Entonces, que la alineación
es casi toda de la que
habían fichado anteriormente otros directores deportivos
como Johan Lanz. Sí, pero
también tenían más margen para la ficha.
El sustituto de
Monchi en su puesto, según
David Ornstein y muchas
fuentes fiables que ya lo dan por cerrado,
es Roberto Olave, el cual
ya intentó fichar el Villa
en 2023, pero se descartó
para quedarse finalmente con
Monchi. Es exportero de la Real Sociedad
y a la vez de Mirandés.
Y tras retirarse se hizo entrenador del juvenil
de la Real y llegó a ser
entrenador interino del primer equipo antes de
pasar a ser director deportivo, donde realmente
se ha especializado y hecho un hueco en las
oficinas del fútbol profesional. En su primera
etapa, la Real casi gana la Liga
2002-2003.
Esa es la primera etapa.
Y ahí se marchó la Almería, cosa que yo
evidentemente no recordaba y fue donde
concedió por primera vez con
una EMERI. Ahí está Jesús.
¡Qué camisa, hijo! ¡Qué camisa, hijo!
La camisa grita 2007.
Y ya los patrocinios
de ciertas cajas, que no creo que ya
existan. ¡La leche! ¡La España!
que ya no es.
Quiero que se valore el trabajo
de Jesús que ha
desenfocado estos dos señores, que ahora mismo
no sabemos quiénes son.
No estemos ubicados, pero ellos estaban
enfocados en la imagen y Jesús ha decidido
enfocarlos. ¿Quieres que te llamemos a partir de ahora
el blurreador profesional?
Focus.
Jesús Focus Sánchez. Ojalá hayas blurreado
a la mayor instrucción que apisa
Almería en su vida.
Que sea el alcalde de Almería, el alcalde
que hizo Almería a ser lo que es hoy en día
y el que hizo que la Almería...
O sea, un hombre que tiene una plaza con su nombre
en Almería, el señor más querido
por la ciudad. Pues que sepáis que lo ha
blurreado. Coge Focus
y lo borroso, macho.
Lo pone borroso. Pues después de
la Almería, Olave tiene una carrera bastante curiosa
porque fue director deportivo del Valladolid,
entrenador del Real Unión,
se fue a la Espada Academia Catarí
a ayudar a Catar, a preparar el mundial
2022 y lo más importante
y que sabrán, sobre todo los ecuatorianos,
se fue a llevar la estrategia
de scout y de academias de Independiente
del Valle. Y tú dirás, oye, ¿quién
ha salido de Independiente del Valle para que sea esto tan importante?
Yo te lo digo. Moisés Caicedo,
Pierre Encapié. Ellos dos
salieron del equipo ecuatoriano mientras
Olave estaba en el
equipo. Luego volvió a la Real Sociedad
en 2016 donde fue director deportivo
hasta este verano. Casi una década, ¿eh?
Una década que además coincide con...
Bueno, según... Bueno, le preguntan
chozas y en general a todos los aficionados de la Real Sociedad,
la etapa más gloriosa
del equipo norte de España desde los años 80.
Campeones de copa. Campeones de copa,
muchos años seguidos en Europa, jugadores como
Odegaard, Merino, Zubimendi,
Isaac, David Silva, Nacho Monreal...
Bueno, lo ha hecho muy bien Olave en la Real Sociedad.
Es una persona que
según cuentan está acostumbrada a implementar
una estrategia general y una filosofía
en el club más que ser un guru de los
fichajes. Por tanto, hablamos de un fichaje
estructural que tiene más que ver
con... No sé si cambiar
o al menos
retocar, por decirlo de alguna forma,
la manera de actuar del club
a muchos niveles en la dirección
deportiva. Como ya os decíamos, en la Real Sociedad
además ha tenido mucho poder,
mientras que Emery con Monchi era quien
tenía casi la última palabra en los fichajes
para decidir entre las opciones que le
presentaba Monchi y esto también puede ser
un cambio de paradigma interesante.
Después de presentar todo esto que está
sucediendo en el Aston Villa tanto a nivel deportivo
como a nivel en los despachos, hay dos preguntas
que se está haciendo la gente.
Si puede remontar el Villa a situación a nivel deportivo
y si peligra el proyecto de
Emery y de Damiab y de Gain
en Birmingham, respetando la segunda y creo que
es más sencilla, a mí
me ha dado tranquilidad cuando he visto que el hombre
era Roberto Lave, porque si de repente
lo que suena es un Ross Wilson de la vida,
el director deportivo, el Forrest que se está
relacionando con el Newcastle... No había otro.
No había otro para poner un mal ejemplo.
No había otro.
Ross Wilson, impecable trabajo
en los Rangers, en el Nottingham Forest
y ahora en el Newcastle.
No había otro. ¿A quién ha matado Ross Wilson?
A tu abuela. Se presentó
un día ahí con una pistola y le dijo
¡Vieja, muera! Y la mató.
Tiene cara de caricatura o no tiene cara de caricatura?
¿Ves que vamos?
¿Qué tiene que ver que parezca
un dibujo animado con que lo pongas de ejemplo?
Es que poco más y mencionas a Ross Wilson
la misma frase que Osama Bin Laden, coño.
El tema es que si
la chef's a Whiris llegan a decidirse por
un inglés como Ross Wilson o un británico
como Ross Wilson, lo que me estaré dando la impresión
es que ya no confían tanto en el proyecto
de Emery y de Damiab, pero vuelven a apostar
por una figura muy relacionada con Emery
y también con Damiabidegaid.
Me da la sensación de, como hemos dicho,
la estructura deportiva de las Don Villa
por como informó The Athletic, básicamente
era Damià, Monchi y Unai.
Y se acabó. Y que el Villa está
también protegido. Que no hable nadie.
Fuera, no sabéis de fútbol. Y creo que el Villa
se está protegiendo ante una eventual salida de Unai
y Emery. O sea, el Villa como proyecto
es unai y Emery. Mañana se cansa, de repente
se quedaba no solo sin entrenador, sino también
sin director deportivo. Ahí sí que cambia todo.
Entonces me parece que tiene sentido traer a Olave,
que es una persona cercana a Emery,
pero que también es alguien que te va a hacer
una estructura deportiva de cara a futuro.
Cosa de con Monchi no estaba pasando.
En fin, es un momento
complicado para el Aston Villa.
Se está juntando el pesimismo
reinante ahora mismo en la ciudad
deportiva después de unos años muy buenos a la
orden de Unai y Emery.
Daba la sensación de que era un club que siempre
iba hacia arriba y ahora es cuando está
experimentando ese valle de rendimiento.
A mí algo de miedo que me daba la plantilla
era que se quedase algo corta tanto
de talento como efectivos.
Me gustaron esos fichajes a última hora de
Sancho y de Harvey Elliot,
pero necesita un impacto ya prácticamente
inmediato de ellos dos para cambiar la dinámica
del club.
Los próximos partidos
son contra Fulham en casa, Burnley en casa,
Tottenham fuera, Manchester City
en casa y Liverpool fuera.
¡Buff!
O me ganas al Fulham o al Barley
o se te va a poner ya complicada
una posibilidad de clasificación europea.
Tottenham, City, Liverpool.
Al menos llegar con victorias
o buenos resultados contra Fulham y
Burnley ya te asegura que los próximos
tres partidos contra el Big Six
vas a tener un subidón de confianza
necesario porque como no saques de ahí buenos
resultados el equipo va a llegar hundido a
esta subida
a un puerto que no me gustaría.
Esto no es de montaña, esto es puerto.
A mí he de decir que me sale ser un poco positivo
en Aston Villa por una IEM Eric porque me parece
que tiene unos mejores entrenadores de toda la
Premier League, el equipo villano y porque
espero y revisando hoy mismo me he vuelto a ver
el partido contra el Sunderland, espero que
cuando Eliott sea titular junto con
Thielemans el equipo cambie mucho.
Evidentemente no es que Eliott
hiciese 57 ocasiones de gol contra
el Sunderland pero se vio otra cosa
y creo que el once que va a acabar jugando
esta temporada en Aston Villa va a ser
muy diferente a lo que vimos contra el Sunderland.
Thielemans tiene que ser titular, Sancho
tiene que ser titular o al menos Ghezal
no tiene que serlo tal y como ha empezado
y Harvey Eliott tiene que ser titular.
Cuando juntas esos tres nombres
más Morgan Rogers, más Holly Watkins
y encima el banquillo esto una IEM Eric
me sale ser positivo.
Yo me imagino un once con Thielemans-Camara
por delante Eliott, por la izquierda Sancho
por la derecha Rogers que la he usado también
muchas veces una IEM Eric y en punta
Watkins y creo que es un once para ir
remontando en cuanto a puntos.
No sé yo si este inicio de temporada te va a lastrar
tanto como para ya a final de temporada
acordarte de estos partidos en los que no estás
puntuando como se le presupone a la Aston Villa
pero sí que creo que es una
plantilla como para, hombre,
pensar que con ese once
vas a ser competitivo.
Sigues teniendo muchos problemas
el lateral derecho coincido
que creo que no está al nivel
se te queda un poco a medio camino
el cambio de ese relevo
en la portería con lo de que
si Divu Martínez se iba, se despedía
luego resulta que ahora vuelve a jugar
son consecuencias de este mercado
que ha dejado tanto caído a la Aston Villa
pero, hombre, sigo pensando
es un equipo para estar en el top ten
peleando por puestos europeos, a lo mejor no para
molestar a los cinco que quieran entrar
en Champions, no olvidemos que tienen también
competición europea a la Aston Villa y esto
me parece una plantilla que no es muy larga para
esto. Pero por otro lado
la mitad de las veces que una IEMería
jugó al Europa League las ha ganado, 4 de 8.
Ya, pero bueno, este reto
también es complicado, no lo descarto
ni mucho menos que es un experto en esta
competición. Bueno amigos, decidnos qué pensáis
de la Aston Villa esta temporada si creéis
que el proyecto va a despegar otra vez
en el presente curso o es un año más
de transición por todos los problemas
que han tenido con el Fair Play Financier
que recordad, tenemos un vídeo hablando del tema
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo
chau.
Drink it in!